stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find it if they grow up to be classy or
into just a big old piece of trash i'm
your host age foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antony's basement she is extremely
excited for our guest i was upstairs she
has a baby pool out in the backyard and
she's on the roof with a football helmet
okay my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the ceo of ru
garbage he wears many toupees in the
organization
he's international businessman we love
him give it up for kj kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true to roof just hit 40 000
subscribers uh and then obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage sign up get a bunch of
content it's [ __ ] nice check it out
very nice and having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
target audience look at him t-boned
mcscruffins toby mcbuttons everybody
let's [ __ ] go dude i'm hyped up
finally got someone rad down here these
are these normal bozo somebody kick me
in the nuts
toby was out front a shopping cart yeah
he's been chugging code red since last
night
because gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly and i
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today we got a little star power in
the building she is one of the stars of
the juggernaut hit jackass forever she
is a very funny stand-up comedian and
actor but the big question about his
mind today is she garbage she's the only
person i ever met that was bitten by a
scorpion what so we're gonna go from
there give it up for rachel wolfson
everybody thank you guys thank you for
having me thank you buddy thank you for
coming in we know you're running around
you're busy we appreciate it uh i'm
happy to be here nice fill us in on the
scoop i've heard a couple of things
uh-huh i've heard las vegas yes uh yeah
born and raised in las vegas which is uh
you know some would say that that could
be a trash city
i think everybody yeah
i don't think i don't think there's a
lot of people in there that's 10 out of
10 venice right there people people go
there to get trashed um you know and uh
so yeah i born and raised there but not
in the city city right um well you
weren't going to high school with the
bellagio
no i mean um we
i'm we ended up as i got older moving to
the suburbs of las vegas but you started
out you guys you were in the city i mean
my zip code is las vegas like las vegas
is more than just the strip yeah um you
know there's uh there's you know
surrounding areas and whatnot and then
like as i got older and my parents
started doing well they moved us to the
suburbs were you in an apartment when
you were first born when i first bought
i don't remember if i was in an
apartment or like it was like the bridal
suite
yeah
i'm like did caesar's palace have a
basement i can't remember
um but yeah it was uh you know they were
just starting off in their career when i
was born so um i mean
it as as i got older the um the living
quarters got better
that's the first time i've ever heard it
referred to as living quarters so that's
pretty good because what i picture is
either somebody lives like near the
strip like uh like william h macy in the
cooler or you live out in the kind of
burbs like where yeah de niro lived in
casino right that's what i'm picturing
yeah that's that you're you're you're
what you're picturing is accurate okay
um so yeah i was born born and raised
there and uh when i was 17 my parents
sent me to a lockdown in provo utah for
a year what's a lockdown uh it's a uh
it's like a it's like a therapy the term
is technically a therapeutic boarding
school it's like a school for troubled
youth essentially they like steal you in
the middle of the night yeah they're
well i don't know i didn't get i didn't
get escorted but like a bunch of people
did yeah my parents like dropped me off
some sometimes
right some parents would lie to their
kids and be like we're going on a ski
trip to utah jesus like the dog at the
vet right like so [ __ ] up so holy [ __ ]
my parents at least like i knew where i
was going but i didn't realize like what
it was like when i got there so i was
there for my senior year of high school
were you looking forward to it at all or
was that
what was going on
honestly okay so i got caught sinking
out of the house and i was having like i
was just having issues at home and
i wasn't a good student i was in my
senior year and my parents were
concerned about my future okay um and so
i think in their mind they thought this
would be a good place for me to have
some structure and discipline um and
yeah it was it was um sucked yeah it
sucked
i just saw her go back there like i
gotta get out of here i mean yeah it was
yeah so um but i you know i don't regret
it i think it it made it built my
character was it not was it a nice
facility uh no it was in an abandoned
church that they wanted that they
transformed into like a school for
troubled kids oh it's not like the x-men
school we're not talking oh no it's not
like hogwarts or anything
it's um yeah so uh so yeah that was i
was there for for 13 months and then i i
graduated with my high school diploma
there okay um and then i ended up going
to college um in vermont for two years
okay uh at a school for kids who have
learning differences okay
is what the is what we call it now
nicely played she's not mediated
i have actually yeah of course
um when i was growing up uh people
thought i was disabled it just turns out
i was different um
we got rebranded
so shout out the marketing yeah so uh
with yeah um so i was there for two
years and i honestly that's where i
learned how to like write a paper
because i missed out i was just bad at
school i went to okay my most of my high
school and middle school was in a
religious school setting all kinds of
religions like growing up pre-k through
eighth grade i went to a jewish school
my freshman year of high school i was at
a catholic school
yeah and then that i was there for your
parents what are your parents are jewish
um we're not religious okay but
yeah so like um so then but there was no
jewish high schools at the time and the
catholic school was like down near where
they worked so it was like convenient
for them it was just not convenient for
me
did you have to pretend you were italian
walking around no they like knew andre
hey good to see you buddy they knew i
was they knew like they could they could
smell me like you know
um something feels awful throwing holy
water at her every day
lock the doors no one leaves
like as soon as i like got blamed for
jesus's death i was like maybe i should
i feel like and it was rachel yeah
i'm like i i think i should transfer to
[ __ ] i'm sick
and so i ended up leaving there
and going to a lutheran school which is
way was there no public schools what's
happening out there see the public
school in vegas probably dicey um it's
not that well it's just such a great
they're massive dude they're they're
like small i mean it's like any other
city they're like 5 000 kids i i would
have gotten lost in the system
and i also had like you know school was
really difficult for me
yeah so um so that so my mom was like
well we'll send you to this lutheran
school
um and i was there for like two and a
half years and then that's when i got
sent to the lockdown so
um so i ended up going to college in
vermont for two years is that what they
call it is the lockdown it's a locked i
i call it a lockdown because you're not
allowed to leave you weren't allowed to
leave no no you you had to earn like you
had to go through a program you weren't
even allowed shoes when you first got
there because they were afraid you're
going to run god damn yeah it's like kid
prison but i don't want to insult actual
people who've gone to prison
but it's it's it's like you know
the idea is to rehabilitate and
reform i imagine the cafeteria sucked oh
my god there they served this one meal
they called steak
[Laughter]
but it was just like this gray piece of
meat
and like there was always cats in the
kitchen so i'm just like i don't know
what i don't know
mr sprinkles i don't know i just i don't
know i don't know what i was ever really
eating um i had a bunch of homies who
went to similar programs they make you
sleep on the ground outside so there a
lot of these programs um are associated
with wilderness programs and my parents
they didn't send me to a wilderness
program which um i was always curious
about how that would have turned out for
me because they send these kids to a
program like that in the middle of
winter to like march around all day and
set up tents and like [ __ ] make their
own food because it's like they're
they're they're doing like the mori
method you know they're like trying to
scare you straight yeah yeah yeah yeah
like
gym class and a little kickball yeah no
um
none of that um and and so like kids
would like get sick or um have frostbite
and would have to end up going to like
being filtered into these um facilities
because they're indoor like one girl i
remember she came to us from a
wilderness program and she showed up
with giardia do you know what that is
you get it from drinking dirty water so
she was like drinking from the rivers
and the creeks not thinking
um maybe i shouldn't be doing that and
she ended up getting like i think it's
like a virus or a disease or something
you have it forever you have it forever
yeah she i think she has it i think you
have it forever i don't know but anyways
so i so i was there for so i i i left
there i graduated i got out and then um
i was in vermont for two years i
graduated from there and then i
transferred to american dc in washington
university that's a great school it's a
great school but i was definitely the
dumbest person in all my classes
and like i don't know i just i thought
maybe i would go into either um
like tv news reporting because i was in
the school of communications um which to
me is like such a joke when you tell
people you're a communication major
um and then um
i was there for about a year and i
realized like
the um
becoming a tv news reporter is not how
it seems on tv like when you they make
you cut your hair you have to move to
kentucky and report on animals like
weird yeah it's just like i i just was
like no i don't really want to do that
yeah you have to like start out working
like the bee clubs
you can't just start headlining
you're not in la you're not new york
you're in [ __ ] alabama and uh you're
not walking into 30 rock you're doing it
doing the weather in minneapolis i was a
weatherman he had to start out like in
some you know like omaha or some
[ __ ] city in the middle of nowhere
and like work his way up the ranks yeah
and and so um
and so i i was there for like a year
and then i remember looking on social
media and seeing a bunch of my
classmates who i'd gone to school with
in vermont moved down to florida to
finish up their schooling and they were
on like yachts and boats and i'm [ __ ]
freezing my ass in dc and hadn't seen
the sun in three weeks so
i like i told my parents i was like
listen like i think i need to
i think i need to like take my talents
elsewhere
like she's a little bronze to south
florida
i'm going to miami i need to go to south
florida mom dad i'm gonna become a free
agent next year yeah and so uh i moved
down to florida where i was like
literally the smartest person in all my
classes i imagine this is where the
story's gonna take a little bit of a
lifetime
down there in fla so i was there uh i
finished up school i got my master's i
started working in the restaurants jesus
you got your masters oh yeah so you got
your bachelors from american university
i got my bachelor's from uh lynn
university in florida i i took my um the
whatever credits i managed to get in dc
and transferred them okay
to florida got my bachelor's got my
masters it's pretty good yeah was
working in and out the restaurants
during college i mean i i worked in and
out the hospitality industry since i was
15. my mom made sure as soon as i could
work i would go to work i would start
working okay um that was in vegas yeah
one of my first jobs was the pool
attendant at the venetian really yeah i
would give people towels
um that's all right what's the tip
situation dude i remember like my first
big tip was when my dad surprised me at
work and just gave me 20 bucks
i thought you're going to say some
japanese high roller was greased you
know like somebody ran for a bottle of
pellegrino
yeah
dad showed up and gave me 20. that's
great he was uh yeah i think you know he
felt bad but um
yeah so so i when i was in college when
i was finishing up my masters i was
working as a hostess at a restaurant in
downtown boca raton and the owner of
that restaurant hired me to come
work for his other company was which was
an organic pizza corporation okay and i
was to be the social media manager which
for stoner is like okay dream job
hanging out tweeting all day yeah just
like tweeting pizza um and so i worked
there for a while and then at a certain
point i just like realized that um
like i had reached kind of like where i
was gonna be in florida like no one
around me worked um no one has to work i
don't get that down there oh yeah i mean
yeah so you're hanging out with rich
kids oh yeah i mean like i'm hanging out
with kids who either have like family
companies they can
work at if they if they got their [ __ ]
together or just kids who didn't have to
work and i just didn't share that um i
just don't come from that was that was
that what a lot of the people at the
vermont school was it was more it was
more of a rich kid school vermont not
necessarily like vermont was a lot of
kids who who had learning differences
who uh that was but school but lynn
university is like very much um
yeah it's like you're going around
you're you're going to school i mean
there's a range always because you have
kids from all different backgrounds but
the majority like it has a reputation
for having like significantly wealthy
children going okay yeah so far this
sounds pretty classy yeah a little bit
of hiccup with yeah with the outward
bound yeah
that's so funny yeah so um
so yeah then um
i told my boss and i was like i just i i
want to move out to la this was in 2013.
uh
and my boss was very cool and let me
work remotely as i transitioned to l.a
so at least i came to la with a job
there you go you know and then i just
like took every job i could in los
angeles while i was doing that i i mean
i i did
all kinds of things not like anything
weird but
the way you were setting it up sounded
like you were like you were a hitman
remembering like all the like in in
retrospect i'm like wow that was like
such a
like what was that you know what i mean
i i worked in and out of the restaurants
i did social media marketing for clients
and things like that so um yeah i mean i
did what i could to to to make money and
um kind of network myself out in l.a
great she's pretty clissy
i have a sister she is a lawyer she's
five years younger than me okay uh
followed in the parents footsteps what
does your mom and dad do exactly um so
my mom is so my mom is a mediator she
used to be a judge okay she used to be
she was a judge that put o.j simpson in
prison for the robbery case whoa what
in las vegas all right here we go yeah
and then it's also like you know it's
that's kind of a trashy crying to be
known for though for sure you know what
i mean what are you talking about she's
judging vegas i know what i'm just
saying should you push a button on
youtube
she's the guy who put o.j in jail yeah
great line so um so there's so this
call by the way yeah
and then my dad is currently the
district attorney of las vegas damn what
yeah holy [ __ ] so
so we get hemmed up in vegas we got a
friend get get us out i i don't know if
i'm gonna be able to do that because
like if i got in trouble in vegas my
parents would be like uh we don't know
you i'm like but we share the same last
name yeah
must be from out of town we've never
seen it yeah
all right so that that that paints the
picture a little bit more well they were
pretty persistent about that and it
seems like it worked out everything you
got your [ __ ] master's got a good
workout
yeah good um
yeah and then i started
comedy in 2016 so three years after i
got to l.a well so that's only your
sister right you said you only had one
sister one younger sister uh was that
your family out there like cousins and
[ __ ] or was it just you guys out there
in vegas oh no my well i have my aunt uh
my grandpa's out there so your whole
family's out there uh part of part of
parts of my family were they there did
your your mom and dad grow up there are
they just my mom is there uh my mom is
born in new york um went uh
when she was 12 she moved to georgia and
my dad is from los angeles so i have la
and new york yeah okay yeah okay
pretty classy so far
i don't know if you can see the finger
tattoos i'm just saying oh yeah
they look like they look like she got it
at the lock up
no this one i got or one of these i got
not the lock down but did you get
there we go
tattoos in case anyone's wondering my
trash level yeah you didn't get that in
boca raton
in vegas
is that the vegas area code on your
wrist it
do you have any does anybody gamble in
your family does everybody like to
gamble no no nothing like that
nobody working security at harrah's or
anything
no no no okay
did you get any trouble when you were in
the lockup any riots or anything like
that uh making your own booze
i did um did you shank anybody
but i did kiss a boy um
which was a huge no gross am i right
it's a huge no-no i'm listening to a
huge no-no because they tried to keep us
separate it was a co-ed school but they
very much did not want us to like really
interact with each other and like
getting co-ed privilege like that was
something that was rare and we had to
earn as like supervised visits with the
others with the opposite sex damn kip
let's talk about box awesome baby box oh
awesome i'm talking about bespoke post
don't be a bozo best post in the world
is that bespoke post they are tell you
what those box of awesomes ain't too
shabby it's the winner whatever you're
into outdoor stuff if you like grooming
materials if you like things for your
home bar every month they send you a
literal box of awesome yeah if i told
you once i told you a thousand times
they sent us gear and we're using it we
got the duffel bag i take on a row with
me i got a knife that i open up all my
amazon packages with
pocket knife martini shape feel like
crocodile dundee in my apartment i got
it on my belt all small businesses all
handcrafted and fantastic yeah uh it's
free to sign up and you can skip a month
at any time they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories it's new guys it's cool guys
[ __ ] you didn't know you knew until you
you don't you didn't know you need until
you see it i'm sure it's super expensive
though right uh no because you know why
you get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the promo code
garbage at the checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for twenty
percent off your first box box of
awesome.com code garbage do it yeah
kirby let's talk about helix you know
him a helix man yeah i know you're a
felix man i could use a mattress over
here all right i'm laying on old dirty
laundry and word on the street best
night's sleep of your life with a helix
mattress you don't got to go to the
mattress store and walk around with some
bizarre over there in a you know a
button-up short sleeve shirt and a
clip-on tie you go over to the website
easy-peasy you take the quiz they find
out how you like this you're probably
going the quiz is probably what 20 25
minutes two minutes two minutes sleep
quick
you're taking two minutes sleep quiz
pick them up i gotta hit uh uh i got i
got me me me and a bird took it we got
matched up with the twilight mattress
and baby it's like twilight everything
i'm [ __ ] twinkle toes over there now
you sleep bald is that right
and bottomless
uh everyone's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from soft
medium firm mattresses matches are great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
great for spinal alignment prevent
morning aches and pains don't forget the
big fellas they even got helix plus
mattresses for the big man
uh so if you're looking for a new
mattress check out helix sleep helix was
awarded number one best overall mattress
pick by 20
of 2020 by gq and wired magazine just go
to helixsleep.com
slash garbage take your two minute sleep
quiz i'll match you with a customized
mattress and give you the best sleep of
your life uh 10-year warranty and you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free we'll even pick it up if you
don't love it but i'm telling you it's
got the kp stand of approval you're
gonna love it yeah felix is offering up
to two hundred dollars off all
mattresses all off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at healixsleep.com garbage one more time
that's heel sleep.com garbage do it yes
um i never got caught for kissing a boy
there but i did get caught so when my
parents came to visit
um
my sister
i used her cell phone to check my
voicemails this was back in the day
where uh yeah people were still leaving
voicemails and she caught me
checking my voicemail because a lot of
my friends didn't know what happened to
me i just was like whoa take like they
were like what happened to her
and so um she caught me checking my
voicemail and because she was younger
and she was like under you know my
parents um
you know i don't want to say spell but
uh influence
she told on me and i had to stay there
longer
and i got i got um so like in lockdown
if you get in trouble they give you
consequences that's what they're called
and consequences
are a half hour of either um working out
intense working out uh homework
or um uh cleaning the tampon boxes in
the bathroom god damn
they ever put you in the hole they have
a hole there they did they had a pin
they had a whole 30 days in a hole jesus
they had like the cool hand luke it's
called isu isolation unit intense
supervision intense supervision unit um
so isu i i went there once because uh
when i was there
i was um
they so i was diagnosed when i was 12
with being bipolar but i actually uh was
misdiagnosed and mis-medicated for it so
i was i was on medication at the time
that in retrospect i didn't need to be
on okay so they they started to take me
off the medication but it really wasn't
the best environment for me to be doing
that sure and so um something triggered
me while i was like going off in this
process at school i think i was working
on english and the teacher wanted me to
work on math which i'm like i'm not
working on math bro like sorry
um and then we got into it and i had a
[ __ ] meltdown and they put me in the
isu for probably a couple hours but a
couple
there would be people they would have to
tranquilize um
kids yeah
[ __ ]
yeah that's where the because the way
you make it sound like it's in the
church there's cats running around but
yet these people have access to
tranquilizers um well they have they
have like doc they had doctors uh well i
mean like a lot of the students there
are on medication so they had to have
people around because we you know we all
have behavioral problems and everyone
treats those differently so i also think
there's a lot of like this happened a
lot in like the
nine like it's coming out now that these
places were like not fantastic oh yeah
they were like they're like absolutely
horrible and for profit yeah yeah yeah
so like paris hilton went to one down
the road from me i think years before i
went to but it's in the same town
because in this town of provo utah they
haven't they have a ton of these schools
for whatever reason i think idaho has
some and like they even have some like
in mexico like like i don't know
sure yes what out of the country yeah
dude that's like guantanamo like
horrible it's like a cia black site
horrible like all over i mean there's
there's so many because these these are
money makers i mean like people kids
want to send parents it's all like
government contracts and [ __ ] you get
right some kids are court ordered there
so i'm wondering if like judges maybe
get kickbacks for those and then like
obviously some people their parents and
families send them there so
um
so yeah it was um
it was a intense place damn that's
serious business the hole
i used to get my parents get pissed off
if i got the attention
that's hilarious
yeah you know how good you got it fatty
you went to high school at shawshank
jesus christ hilarious
that's crazy dude there was some there
was some crazy [ __ ] like that that
happened there
for sure can't do your heart is nailed
unbelievable that is crazy but let's get
into some more garbage questions here oh
yeah all right let's run down a couple
of things
um
your parents don't live in the same
street that you grew up on right you
guys
what was the name of the first street
where you were born your first house
carly drive that's pretty good not bad
was it an apartment or a house i i want
i think it was a house
i don't remember in vegas yeah yeah yeah
what grocery store would your mom go to
out there probably like uh
vaughn's or albertsons or just eat at
the buffet every day i mean
i don't know what the yeah i don't know
would you guys ever go to the casinos
for like a family dinner oh yeah for
sure we actually had to live in a in one
of the hotels um up by us not like one
on the strip because our house got mold
in it okay like black mold because when
they built my parents shower they just
did it incorrectly and so like water
like it they kept having a leak
we would be sitting down in the kitchen
you just see this like leak
occurring in the ceiling and so they
would try they would try to like repair
it but they didn't realize they had to
go deeper so at one day they like
cut open the shower and it was just a
wall of ants everybody get out of ants
dude they were just like feasting on
like whatever rotted it was just like
disgusting um so we had to
move out of the house they have they had
to like dry clean like the it wasn't
their fault it was the builder's fault
so the builders had to like come in redo
it pay for all of our everything to get
like did you have one of those tents
over your house oh yeah one yeah
they covered everything because like you
have to get every article of clothing
like cleaned too yikes it's like bed
bugs yeah those are terrible vegas
bedbugs so like my that was my junior
year of high school and so we stayed up
at the suncoast hotel which is a local
casino um and like i just smelled i just
smelled like smoke every day going to
school typical
sorry i was at the tables all morning
what do you want from me
holy [ __ ] oh so that's pretty trashy
like going to school you're 17 you smell
like cigarettes yeah you're leaving a
casino to go to high school that's a bad
look yeah did any of your homies in high
school sneak in like play underage and
win any like a substantial amount of
cash no dude that's like they like
even if you look young there's people
checking like you don't even like walk
they'll make sure you're not like
doing that anywhere near this yeah if
you even look young they'll come right
up to you and check your id because they
could get [ __ ] do you have any of your
friends parents get jammed up at the
casinos
um i don't know anybody who's
blacklisted or anything yeah i don't
know if uh if i like off the top of my
head i don't but i know my parents for
sure do i mean
you know people come there and they they
like spend their kids safe like yeah
they're safe you know it's a real you
never seen me it was a dark aspect oh
yeah 100 you ever seen anybody pulling
anything or anything like that seen
anyone what pawning anything oh pawning
do you know the guys from paul oh do you
know my dad's dude my dad my dad's my
dad does probably are we probably
friends with them no they're like homies
they're homies
on a dui
they're always in my pocket
they're home
chumley likes the meth i think
yeah no they're my dad definitely no he
knows uh he knows those guys rick
harrison is that the whoever the dad is
yeah wow well the old man yeah he passed
away though or probably yeah the main
guy is rick the best i can you know it's
valued at 14 million the best i can do
is 20 bucks do you want it
damn
wow that's pretty your family knows the
people from pawn stars
did you ever see siegfried and roy when
you were a kid oh yeah really my was one
of my birthdays my my parents took me
they got backstage i got to meet them i
got a stuffed tiger oh yeah that's
pretty good yeah do you know anybody
that was at the performance where he got
mauled
um i don't know anyone who is there okay
but i do remember that happening that
was sad did you ever watch like
implosions of buildings oh yeah i went
to go see
i went to go see
i think it was the stardust
or yeah i saw it live that's [ __ ]
awesome whole family everybody
it was me uh and a boyfriend at the time
it was like it was at night it was it
was insane i always had a pretty sick
date yeah it was cool go to dave and
buster's to go watch him blow up this
building yeah yeah
that's pretty sweet wow good pull kippy
that's great
i love those growing up would your
parents keep the batteries in the
refrigerator
no okay i don't think so anybody in your
family call it a banana
have you ever bought or sold anything on
craigslist
i have definitely bought something off
craigslist a chair
recently
no okay before the pandemic and it was
such a hassle because so like um i'm too
cheap to buy anything from z gallery
because it's so expensive so i'll buy
[ __ ] from z gallery off craigslist like
you know
um and i bought this couch or it was
like it's a chair i still have it but it
was it was so difficult to get like no
one i knew in la had a car that could
like
fit it
and uh and then like moving it into the
building because it's so oddly shaped it
was it's the worst did you haggle
um at all or you just play will you pay
face val or do you haggle no no i think
i didn't buy it for like what she bought
it for but i i um you got it at a
discounted rate yeah okay
when you uh when you buy stuff at the
grocery store will you reach for the
item behind the first one or will you
take the first it depends on what the
item is lay it on me so if it's
something like a milk based or something
that i feel like could give me food
poisoning i'll probably go or like you
know i want to protect you i want the
freshest one oldest one yeah or the cold
yeah especially in a gas station i'm
like oh that the first water is not cold
so i'm gonna go i'm gonna reach all the
way back there yeah you know smart very
good you got to stay on top of these
things yeah
you think it's okay to use tissues as
napkins
listen when in doubt
sometimes if you don't you know so i
will use tissues as toilet paper
but not because i want to but because
sometimes you run out of options yeah up
i would tear right through that that
would be not a good look well that's you
use a handful i'll use a paper towel oh
god that's the chaffage see at least the
i like the con i like the comfort of the
tissues has some like uh lotion on it
there's some lubrication yeah you get
one of the ones with uh vix on there you
could be yeah you're right you're right
hmm if we went to your house right now
what kind of water could you offer us
bottled
what are you what are you working with
um so i just got a uh updated um pure
like you know those little skinny ones
that give out purified
that they're filtered water so is it
hooked up to the faucet it is yeah yeah
so i have that um that's all that's
great so so so when i because it broke
and when the guy came to fix it he was
like yeah you're supposed to change the
filter every six months like the filter
of it was really was black yeah i might
as well have been drinking tap water at
that point it's the healthier option
yeah all right let me ask you this you
have you have the option of one of these
what are you taking
a regular cone a sugar cone a waffle
cone or a pretzel cone ooh
there is a right answer
although i don't disagree with it so you
know it's non-partial i've never even
heard of a pretzel cone so i would
probably go with that just because i've
never even heard of it okay i'm willing
to try anything okay pretzel cone's
pretty good correct answer regular cone
okay ladies and gentlemen i don't know
i don't agree with that the gentleman
goes through the regular cone yeah
pretzel cone you live a little yeah you
go pretzel cone yeah it's got the salt
it's nice toby um never heard of a
pretzel cone i'd probably go sugar cone
it's a gentleman's move too doing a show
with [ __ ] bozos over here
jesus christ any beekeepers in the
family beekeeper no no beekeepers
hmm
let's see have you ever ridden a
mechanical bull
uh
i don't think i have okay i've never
attended a rodeo
i've attended a rodeo i can't remember
if i don't think i have nascar event
uh no no no no nascar air show
no air show boat show regatta
um i've been to a car show
okay any monster truck rallies in there
uh i believe in lockdown they took us to
one of those yeah i got to see a monster
grave digger in the hole baby let's do
it yeah
hmm have you ever been to a live magic
show yeah of course i'm from vegas yeah
lance bird probably got sold in halftime
have you ever met chris angel
uh uh and fortunately i have not met
those two vegas legends um but they're
i'm hoping there's still time for me
what about wayne newton you're going to
go see wayne newton no
no wayne newton you ever strong arm a
blackjack deal or to play nope not good
i i when it comes to that i'm so bad at
math
um and like she's hitting on thirty-five
i just uh
i wouldn't even yeah i yeah number's not
good for me what were the family
vacations like oh those are dope those
are okay lay it on us so like
international as a kid oh yeah so your
parents were doing in the beginning they
started out so they okay so my mom when
she met my dad was a tv news reporter
okay and my dad
in vegas local so she started off in
radio and then moved out to vegas and
started working in radio and tv well she
was like a local celebrity like yuki
washington she uh i don't know yeah i
mean i think she um i don't i i don't
know how popular she i wasn't even alive
then so she was reporting on stories in
the courthouse and my dad was a
prosecutor like a young new lawyer
prosecutor and he would pass her movie
this is something
right now in the hallways and he would
he would say i'm going to marry that
girl yeah i'm already thinking about
casting i like a young i like a young
andy garcia hilarious hilarious
um
so what was that what was the question i
don't know i forget yeah
vacation vacation
i'm all steamed up over here so they
yeah so like you know they were doing
well as i was growing up they started
taking us
um on vacations and
um
uh
sometimes they would bring a babysitter
so they could like that's a little bit
of cash they would uh
so they could like you know enjoy their
vacation just don't bring us you know
what i mean um but the but
there's a
but the babysitter they would so you're
thinking like an au pair the people they
would hire to watch us were criminals
like literally trash we had this one
nanny
we had this one babysitter
she was a straight-up babysitter as soon
as she got to the hotel she raided the
mini bar because she thought those were
for free she had never
gone
you know so my dad goes down and this is
the night where are you guys at would
you think we're in mexico okay and so
all-inclusive resort i don't remember um
i i don't know if it was or not but she
took everything out of the mini bar and
my dad goes downstairs and he's like why
do i have a 400 charge in the in the
girls room for
for alcohol and so um i think he made
her put it back but like in the 90s 400
dollars for for is like oh yeah yeah
it's insane it's a lot of money so you
guys would have two rooms they would
have their room and then you and your
sister would be in with the nanny yeah
with the babysitter
nanny sounds classy this woman chain
smoked and [ __ ] drink that's a
babysitter and [ __ ] like she okay so
you wanna hear trash
so growing up
sherry is her name and um she was the
worst um so my parents my parents would
go you know have date night or something
and sherry would drive us to go well she
would drive us to her friend's house
leave us in the car while she would go
play poker
like that is not a nanny didn't you guys
tell your parents this when you're like
i would try to like i i was so young
that i don't even think i could like
articulate like she didn't know what
just happened you know she's in there
playing [ __ ] pictures and so and so
but i did try to communicate to them
like hey some of the people you're
hiring are not like they're not like
they're not like qualified to watch
children like they ha my mom at one
point got so desperate she hired a guy
named scott to watch that's not good
that is not good i don't have kids but
that's a no-go he's the worst dude like
he is not a [ __ ] babysitter
his name's scott yeah
no there's no i'll take a sherry any day
of the week yeah i hear scott's coming
over i'm under the bed hey you kids want
to learn how to make long distance calls
for free like i feel like like rich kids
like they hire nannies to teach their
kids like spanish and italian like okay
my gosh like nanny's also
a nanny also implies like a longer
duration of higher right that was my
nanny all through my childhood a
babysitter's like nanny's wear uniform
and go right yeah like scott has a
leather jacket right and delivers pizza
wine shorts yeah like exactly scott
wears shorts yeah cut off once cut off
george how old was scott um probably at
that time he's got he probably was in
his like thirties that's so [ __ ]
weird it's weird dude it's [ __ ] weird
look he didn't get kidnapped oh scott
was the worst no scott was like he was
like he was like the boyfriend of a
mom's like
that's that's even weirder of my mom's
friend so um
you know scott moonlights as a
babysitter what the [ __ ] he's a manny
manny
man but um yeah jesus
that's that's
see the money doesn't guarantee it look
at that right there
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy
ladies and gentlemen if you have
something in your life that's holding
you back all right whether it's a
relationship
uh whether it's uh trouble at work
whatever you need better help can help
because you got to remember something
the most important relationship you have
in your life is with yourself yes you
got to take care of yourself and better
help can help they got your back better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
nope if you're a little shy guy little
shy gal that's easy peasy you do it all
via text or voicemail whatever it's much
more affordable than in person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours so it's real easy to
get started plus they have a specialist
that might not be available in your area
yeah so give it a try and see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and all you garbage
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com garbage that's better
help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
garbage do it yeah kip let's talk about
athletic greens athletic greens for
these guns
that's about 25 athletic greens right
there
mcdonald's hit me up
i've been using it every day yeah i take
it to the gym it's easy peasy it tastes
good he's even got a green shirt on he's
all green i'm all green man i'm all i'm
all like g1 baby you get your vitamins
you get your gut health you get your
immunity it's absolutely fantastic and
i'm telling you my workouts are better
okay i know i'm a big big fatty but
athletic greens has helped me change
that my workouts are better when i have
that with me to have to sip in between
when i'm getting huge doing my reps i'm
getting swole down i'm doing my goblet
of squats and my db presses look out uh
guys everybody's taking some sort of
multivitamin this that the other thing
and they're taking photos it's a one
shot stop taking 15 pills a day you
don't have to do that ag one's got you
covered it's lifestyle friendly whether
you're doing keto paleo vegan free dairy
free gluten-free contains less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
no artificial anything still tastes good
uh right now is the time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
the com with a convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into cold
and flu season just one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com garbage again one
more time that's athleticgreens.com
garbage should take ownership of your
health today do it good job
crazy
yeah
i'm sorry you're staying in a lot of
hotels lately or traveling around a
little bit um
am i staying in a lot of hotels
i got i did i understand you're getting
older
i got uh for the first time i took a
shot what do you want for like two two
days on this trip i got put up via for
the for the press do you drink the
coffee in the rooms i yeah
oh no oh no no no no i order coffee from
room service oh yeah
yeah yeah that's what i was getting if i
if if i was paying for it if i was
paying for it i'd drink the coffee
i don't [ __ ] touch that thing no i i
would definitely i would definitely
probably order it downstairs so hold on
so mex just to go backwards mexico would
be a trip to that you went on as a kid
where else would you guys go um
we went to jamaica
okay um what age we talking like 10 11
12
16. i was young enough um i was i was
young i was like definitely under 16.
because there was a point where we just
misbehaved so bad on vacation that they
were like we're not bringing you kids
anymore like really yeah
um like my sister and i would fight or
it was just it's it's a lie
like a vacation is supposed to be
relaxing me and my brother ruined so
many things yeah so many like i
literally like i just hear it in in my
mind i'm threatening like no more
vacations for you guys yeah like we're
not doing that anymore
um
but yeah i think uh jamaica mexico
uh
yeah that's so you got your passport at
a young age yeah i had a passport i had
it's pretty classy
if you went to a restaurant
and you didn't like the table you got
well you asked for a different table
yeah
sometimes i mean my dad my parents like
my dad is six five and hit
and and so for him he doesn't like to
sit with his back towards the door
he likes to you know he likes to be
comfortable too he says jesus and
italians don't say what they're backing
they don't like yeah
yeah
exactly
his head could end up in that plate of
pasta real quick no [ __ ] yeah but i mean
uh it depends i like that like if
there's like if there's a table they
give us and it's like the whole
restaurant is empty and it's a [ __ ] or
it's like you know i'll be like hey can
we just go to that one sure i just
started doing that a little bit yeah i
mean it if it's a busy if it's busy no
i'm whatever because i worked in
restaurants and i know like you know
like
sometimes they're reserving sometimes
they just can't sit there but i mean if
you just it's all it's all about asking
and being in the situation nice yeah
yeah
damn i'm irish they can put me in like
next to the dumpster but yeah this is
fine thank you
is this the grease trap all right thanks
love it we'll pay extra
to pee in the shower oh hell yeah brush
your teeth in the shower he does my my
boyfriend does which i i i'm always like
why is the toothpaste in the shower do
you keep the toothbrush in there yes
it travels
that's a bad look
no the other day uh i i realized half
way through that i was using his
toothbrush
um how do you feel about that stop
you're okay with it same germs right
you're fine with it
yeah no me too i'm cool with it uh-uh
you can't use your wife's toothbrush i
could i would um
yeah i'd be feel weird for a couple of
days i felt weird for a second but i was
like no i mean
once that second's over it's already too
late he's into it he's into it that's
how he gets his rocks
it's our
what kind of toothpaste we working with
uh
whatever's [ __ ] cheap or free i don't
know crest uh or
are we a crust family yeah would you say
you're frugal when it comes to cash
um
it depends no i mean i i'm a spender
like if it comes to weed i buy the best
weed um
yeah your boyfriend almost had a spit
tank
i
i don't think i'm frugal i don't think
i'm frugal i don't think i'm frugal was
there any responsible purchase with your
first big check
uh
with my first big check resp any no um
jet skis anything like that oh i have
that i just spent the 20 your dad gave
you
i spent that on some weed no
i didn't even smoke weed back then
probably like um
i don't even know
food yeah okay uh do you travel first
class fly first class okay if you're
buying no no but on the way out here
i got hooked up and now i got i got a
little taste of the delta right
and i was like i can't fly i've been
ruined like i i can't i can't sit in i'm
i'm just like emotionally trying to
prepare myself for having to like go
back to the coach you know
um so i got my i've never flown first
class until this trip and i'm like wow
how much better is the food up there oh
my god i had a charcuterie in the air
they should be on two different planes i
don't even understand i'm like how is
this yeah i mean i was sleeping on a i
was laying like flat
um
yeah i'm spoiled i also went i also they
like uh you know jackass took us to our
first well to my first ufc fight
and we had the best seats in the house
like literally the only people sitting
in front of us was joe rogan nice like
and who's that exactly uh no
but i'm i mean i could see his head you
know i could like see the shine i was
very very close um
um so now i'm ruined for that forever
like how am i supposed to go back yeah
yeah no kidding hmm
are you tsa pre-check
um i'm uh what is that one clear i just
got clear because with with comedy and
traveling so i i opened for my friend
felipe esparza i was really really great
comedian and he's the one who showed me
um clear clear what's the credit score
like
i don't even have a credit card really
no
you don't have the credit i just you
debit it it scares the [ __ ] out of me
wow have you never had a credit card no
holy [ __ ] i think my parents gave me
like a a just like for emergencies
because i was on the east coast and they
were they were scared
uh it had like a limit on it but um
they took that [ __ ] away years ago you
don't got an amex capital one nothing
wow i got a visa baby okay
i hope one day i'll i'll be like in a
good place where i could have it you
know okay why do you think you would you
would recklessly spend on it i don't
think so but it's just the fact that i
have it there
knowing like oh i can that thing that i
want to do i could probably do it right
now oh [ __ ] um if i yeah if i want to
hop on a first class flight
you know what i'm saying so i i don't
know if the temptation is good for me
well that's good that's good you're
disciplined enough not to do it i'm the
other way i got it sitting burning a
hole in my pocket yeah ready to make a
move
um anyone in your family own a
convertible if so what kind
so um
they my dad at one point purchased a
old school volkswagen okay um because it
was like always his dream i think he had
one as a kid and like he wanted you know
he was going through something so he was
like i'm going to purchase
an old school one and it was literally
the worst purchase i mean he bought it
in california drove it back to las vegas
and it broke down on the way
right after he purchased it so we had
that sitting in
driveway for for many years that's a
tough one it's a bad look for a d.a yeah
it wasn't on the grass right it was on
the driveway it was in the driveway all
right the grass is respectful were the
tires awful
was there flat tires no flat tires
there's a cover over it or half over it
um no
um
the convertible part has that like black
cup like sure um so yeah that that was
it just bacon in the vegas sun for a
couple years my our ping pong table had
a cover over it though
outside
um no it was in the garage you had a
ping pong table in the garage could you
park a car in the garage or no you could
park a car in the garage so you had a
two-car garage
i bet you guys have a pool we had a pool
in ground yep what what was your mom and
dad whipping around in when you were a
kid what did they draw uh
well i think my dad
so my mom had one of those vans that had
the wood on the side of it yeah she did
shout out to the woody yeah my mom my
mom drove minivans for a while as a
judge she's never been around when she
was a lawyer so like when she okay so
when my mom and dad met my mom was a
a tv news reporter and my dad was a
prosecutor and then my mom ended up
going to law school okay and then she
became a lawyer and then when
and then my dad and her got married and
they opened up a law firm together damn
so these are smart learning people yeah
so then um
like as we got older the cars got better
right like
yeah she the wood panel um
we had that like we had that like maroon
one with the one panel
i think there was red tints on it too
i'm not lying anybody ever drive a lexus
yeah i mean lexus is zipping around they
had alexis early 2000s were talking
yeah with yeah and then probably
recently i feel like they have one nice
i like that
yeah hmm
interesting you're right you're right
yeah go back and forth this is crazy i
know the education is ridiculous i'm
like classy trashy it's like there's a
there's a version of like classy trashy
which i think is like
vegas
yeah what was your first concert
uh new kids on the block baby
okay outside outside uh
it was outside my aunt took me it was i
just remember there being hay i don't
know why there was hay
how much older than using your aunt how
much older is your aunt than you um
i don't know like
like was she an adult when you were a
kid yeah yeah yeah okay
that's a tough look
do you use scented trash bags
uh reluctantly because like i'm i'm more
of a i don't like scented anything like
any like i don't like my trash to smell
like
something like scented trash what about
scented candles you like scented candles
uh
my dad does i think they like make me
kind of nauseous okay and also i have
cats three cats um because i'm unwell
and um
and i'm worried that
that to leave an open flame near them
did you have pets growing up yes what
did you have dogs
and we had a bird we had some birds my
mom went through a phase were they or
that were any of them loose birds no
loose birds but um she had a bird die in
her hand and i remember that day that
was
it had like a heart attack in her hand
um
it's a tough day when the bird yeah when
the bird goes did any of the birds talk
yes uh one said pretty bird
and it would whistle
it was a parakeet
you know when you go to petco you can
get one for like five bucks
you know sure you can buy all their you
could buy all their brothers and sisters
any fish tanks at the house growing up
my dad my dad that was like his flex
like when he
like he was like a shark in there
somewhere
i had a fish tank like eventually like
my dad got a big one um and he would
have salt water fish oh man you know
like that was a flex for him like that
was like oh he's doing good you know
will your parents waterbed people by any
chance
i don't think we had water beds now okay
i wanted one as a kid but i never got
one
any bunk beds as a kid no bunk beds no
bunk beds hmm
what about injuries as a kid oh yeah
what'd you break uh in basketball i
broke my um my ankle i popped a tendon
into a ligament okay um and then i
broke my wrist in basketball
and then i broke my wrist in college a
boxer's fracture
okay what were you doing
i punched something yeah
that's when you put you when you punched
something incorrectly so i um so when i
it's funny because like i didn't tell my
parents the truth i i told them i said
this bone here yeah i told him i slipped
up the stairs
[Laughter]
which they knew like when i got
diagnosed with the boxer fracture
they're like yeah that's uh
that doesn't that doesn't add up the
evidence you were tuning somebody up
that and a cab door got me
do you know any of the lyrics to the rap
battles from eight mile
to the rap battles uh pop a dock isn't
that what that guy's name is yeah and
rap white rabbit whatever happens
if you threw it on i could start i would
start spinning i just wasn't sure some
people have them like tattooed in their
brain oh that's hilarious
not saying me or anything
you sleep with your mouth open
if i'm so tired
uh
like i remember on the plane the other
day i woke myself up snoring
so my mouth was open for sure thanks
sleep with a fan on you i sleep with the
air at like 69 degrees no matter if it's
winter or summer really look at that
nice feeling freezing yeah well how many
pillows multiple pillows i have i i have
so many pillows on the bed right now
well between your leg do you hold one on
the side i have um a body pillow that
goes um against like the headboard i i'm
just stoked i recently got like within
the last year ahead board like to me
that's my that's a fish that's my fish
tank that's that's
was the mattress in the box spring
usually on the floor um i had
so i i had a mattress
on a platform um i didn't and when i
when we moved into our new place i
didn't realize like
your bed is supposed to have a platform
and then i got one and i was like oh wow
this bed is actually really comfortable
i was talking [ __ ] about the bed for so
long but then i realized like i didn't i
just didn't have a complete bed yes i
had half a bed yeah it stinks i only i
have yeah so i i got my first headboard
um since since uh
since
i think like
since i had a headboarding call in the
dorm room yeah gotcha calling a box
spring a platform yeah hilariously
yeah
um anyone in your family own a
standalone hot tub
see the thing in vegas is um absolutely
everyone yeah it's so hot there you you
can't survive without one like
and they're all built in the ground yeah
okay imagine the ac in your house was
probably pretty spectacular yeah yeah my
dad's also a big my dad's also a big um
door open windows open kind of person
favorite candy bar
ooh
um
gosh i haven't had like i feel like i
haven't had a candy bar in so long um
i like snickers classy but right up the
middle
cold
have you ever had one pulled yeah of
course yeah it's way better fantastic
it's pretty classy i'm telling you right
now
how old were you when the when the last
time you went to the pediatrician
were you one of those weirdos that went
till they were like 22.
yeah really
yeah i still remember going to a
pediatrician in like i feel like high
school
yeah that's a tough one yeah yeah
girl scouts
yeah but i got kicked out um nice yeah
yeah i mean also my mom was the one who
was really selling like she was the one
who was with my dealer you know like
dealing the cookies and stuff she would
take the orders to her her work which
was all like you know successful people
and probably cleaned up yeah um what'd
you get kicked out for
i just i just was like a trouble i just
wasn't i just yeah i the trouble making
faces
will you buy clothes wear them and
return them
uh no i usually i usually wear them okay
yeah
do you put your feet on the coffee table
at the house oh yeah i'm sick like i'll
put my feet like on the table in other
people's houses
yeah but i i don't even realize i don't
even realize like i was at one of the
clubs last night i put my feet up on a
chair and i was like oh i sh yeah like i
caught myself doing that
um and then i realized like when i put
my feet up like at home on the coffee
table that's exactly the same place i
also eat
sometimes keep your shoes on in the
house
uh
no we take our shoes we try to take our
shoes off at the entrance okay you guys
have a kitchen table at the house
yeah but it was from the previous owner
like the previous people who live there
do you eat most of your meals on the
couch at the coffee table it depends on
the meal okay yeah and it also depends
on like am i yeah it depends on the meal
and do we cook
sometimes lately i've been because of my
schedule i've been ordering in a lot but
we try to we try to cook sometimes okay
yeah
okay what grocery store did you go to
out there
when i'm ballin it's definitely erwan
but i had to work myself out i said that
i had to work myself up to that because
like when you go into irwin it's not
just a regular grocery store it's a
[ __ ] runway there are no ugly people
allowed like it's only hot people and um
and like everyone is a celebrity that's
like where they you know so if you want
a network go to irwin
you want to make it in l.a just stand by
the juice
the 15 juice box
like literally they sell these immunity
shots which i think are probably six
dollars and it's like that's my entire
paycheck literally right here so that's
awesome um you believe with their
charges for grapefruit but also can i
just say that trader joe's is [ __ ]
amazing you could literally
um
buy uh three weeks worth of food for
forty dollars it's crazy
and the snacks are so lit snacks are
awesome the stuff that they put together
yeah is really good yeah i love trader
joe's i don't know how they're making
any money
um i i don't know because everything
comes from monrovia california which
when you look like if you look at like
i'm like what is happening in this town
you know what i mean like
what's happening everybody walking
around in hawaiian shows yeah yeah yeah
have you ever owned a chia pet
um i don't think i've owned a chia pet
but my mom one time for valentine's day
got my sister and i furbies oh that was
big back in the day it was but like it
wouldn't it wouldn't like it it just
wouldn't stop talking so i threw it off
and threw it off the hat like i threw it
out i threw it off the house
yeah you murdered it this girl's twisted
it yeah
and yeah a car ran over it
and it still was talked about
uh do you like popping other people's
pimples
i make him pop mine though okay yeah i
always yeah i i yeah
that stuff grosses me out okay that's
good yeah i can't believe there's entire
television shows like celebrities yeah
i'm hooked on it yeah i love it there's
people who got famous for i'm popping
multiple yeah ever swam in a river
yeah
how do you feel about quail eggs
i won't eat those
i don't there's something weird like the
size of them yeah they're strange yeah
i don't know when was the last time you
were in a wave pool
okay so in vegas they had this um this
water park called wet and wild
and uh they had a wave pool
and um i almost drowned there
yeah
define almost drown lifeguards came in
and got in i didn't it wasn't the wave
pool that i almost there's one that just
like it was like it would go in a circle
and um it was it had like a current and
i think i got like dragged down and
someone had to like pull me up and
save me essentially hmm
yeah any lifeguards ever have to save
you in the ocean
um no lifeguards had to save me in the
ocean no thank god any shark bites in
your family no no no no
hmm do you sleep with some sort of
weapon near you
um i feel like anything can be a weapon
if you want it to be
like that
that's an answer of a girl who's done
time yeah
i feel like you know i because i think
about that i'm like you know if someone
were to break into my place like what
would i what would i go for and i'm just
a savage like i would i would just pick
up anything heavy if it's like a lamp or
or like even a remote you know
yeah
i'll find anything
those heavy remotes they could cause
i'll take my myself i mean one of those
universal i'll take the apple cord and
tie them up like anything anything can
be a weapon anybody in your family with
a birthday on a holiday
no but my best friend growing up was
born on 9 11. whoa yeah never forget
yeah
and i always remember her birthday so of
course obviously
have you ever written your name in wet
cement
um
wet cement
um
no i've well i've talked
i've like chalk
i've done chalk on this event or that's
that's good clean fun yeah
it's okay it's called being a kid all
right
that's okay don't have to feel bad for
that yeah uh have you ever gone ghost
hunting
ghost hunting i mean no i don't think
i've specifically gone hunting for
ghosts okay okay um that would be ghost
off yeah
anyone in your family smoke a pipe
um i smoke a pipe
a weed pipe yeah yeah okay i mean i
meant not a pipe
oh
no no no no no no no no i don't think so
i don't think i was trying to think if
my grandpa like smoked a like out of a
pipe or something yeah
i think it's clean man yeah i don't know
what to tell you
do you own your own bowling ball
no bull i don't i don't but i do enjoy
bowling
do you have name brand luggage
um recently i got away
the way away yeah yeah recently this is
all this classy stuff is like new to my
shoulder
i just want your followers to know like
i'm newly classy like i've been trash
you know
have you ever been involved in a class
action lawsuit
no but i get those things in the mail
where it's like you may be entitled to
compensation if you took this birth
control during the years
hmm what kind of car do you have now
recently uh after jackass i got a bmw
yeah
i
i i i never had a bmw so uh this is
granola that's awesome lisa you bought
it we bought it yeah this kid's all
right
yeah what kind of air freshener are you
kicking around in there weed bro
that's sticky
yeah
beat it old man yeah
keep magazines in the bathroom
uh no not currently no no no anybody
receive mail at your house that doesn't
live there but not by accident
um
you got a friend anybody using your
address i have had a friend send stuff
to my address for sure
nice
so the associates might not be as classy
oh no i don't discriminate do you buzz
the flight attendant
um
i i no i didn't no i don't i mean
they'll walk by and i'll wave them any
wind chimes on your porch yeah
my dad is obsessed with like that's a
little weird yeah
um
yeah i mean growing up my grandparents
in la they had uh wind chimes so that
was like
on their porch and stuff that was
something that um also really she's not
going to fold to our questioning she
grew up with [ __ ] judges yeah
she's used to this
these are the derogations
you're gonna have to waterboard this one
to get anything out of here i'm ready
let's do it
i think she's pretty classy man yeah not
super i have she walks in both worlds
here
you know what i mean yeah i that's the
thing about me is like i do feel like i
i can't i'm comfortable you can
acclimate i can do as well yeah yeah
yeah you own a drone
my dad owns a drone he's become a drone
this guy sounds like he [ __ ] rocks by
the way
so so matt and him will just they just
that's their they just drone together
yeah
that's pretty yeah
yeah
uh yeah you know karate
so my mom put me in karate class jesus
because some so like i feel like they
were training you to be an assassin well
they're
they were trying to like figure out like
what to do with me i think and i was a
tomboy so i did enjoy
sports and and
and not like your typical girl like i
was always playing soccer or um i did
taekwondo and i got to orange belt um
and then i felt weird doing the fake
kayas it felt like i was like
like appropriating a culture or
something
and uh and so yeah i i think i got to
like uh
the second level orange belt and i was
like okay my career is
that's it for me it's over you fall
asleep with the tv on uh sometimes
sometimes i will mayonnaise hellmann's
or uh miracle whip
if i had to choose it would be hellman's
good good good you ever pull a fire
alarm
um no
i don't want the fine
eat an egg with two yolks in it yeah
yeah okay favorite salad dressing
oh god um i like um
is it is it
is it french the bright the bright red
one that's like basically ketchup with
like sugar in it
yeah
yeah french dressing yikes yeah talk
about a big step back right there i i'm
proud of it dude it's [ __ ] uh my dad
is not catalina catalina's wait is that
okay which one is the creamy one like i
like the bright red one french that's
catalina
yeah
i got nothing else man yeah i mean
50 50. blocks them both 50 50 walks in
bros well but i'm pushing for class and
let me tell you something that stuff
that you overcame as a kid that's pretty
[ __ ] awesome oh thank you and your
family also knows the pawn stars so
that's like uh
that's that's an ayg first we typically
ask have you watched it she knows them
yeah that's pretty cool well i don't
know them but my dad my dad knows them
yeah i might get a hold of him if you
needed to yeah like if i had
ladies and gentlemen rachel wolfson
rachael anything about the ones there to
know oh uh well first off thank you
thank you guys for having me uh yeah
just follow me on social media at rachel
wolfson on instagram at wolfie comedy on
twitter uh that's where i post show
dates and um matt and i will be doing a
show if any if any of your listeners are
out in la we're march 11th at uh the
virgil
and there's tickets um online you can
purchase so come out fantastic thank you
so much congratulations on the movie
yeah guys we're so happy for you it's so
[ __ ] cool kippy what do you got for
him uh we're all over the world we're
announcing more dates this week uh
on the west coast so get those tickets
yeah
we love you and we'll see you next week